can you hear me well at least you can
see it now right with me when we start
looking at the this thing so anyway like
I don't know whether you have seen the
what is that the polar in a Polar
Express right so in that the Tom hang
says if you are looking for penguins
they are on the other end right because
the Penguins around the South Pole and
he is on the North Pole
so like that if you are looking for
recommendations it's on there on the
other end and we are there so this is
pandas data wrangling and data science
in that order pandas is the main focus
with the data wrangling and not going
too deep into data science because it
you know we could do a whole machine
learning tutorial for the whole day or
that kind of stuff right the agenda we
will talk about the data wrangling
pipeline just to get a feel for what
does it mean data wrangling in with
respect to machine learning ecosystem
with respect to data science type of
work right and then we will go into the
basic maneuvers is everybody familiar
with pandas here or there are people who
have in I used to benders before a few
folks are there right okay so but so
that is a good one so that coming and I
didn't know how many people who are in
back and forth we will take a quick the
basic maneuvers right you do you know if
you are looking at things here to at
least look at the basic ones and say
what are the what are the primitives
that we have so we will go quickly go
through the basic maneuvers and then we
will go through multiple data sets the
idea is to look at pandas to learn
pandas to understand the various
mechanisms by doing stuff right rather
than just looking at abstract and saying
these are the APS so that's what we will
do we have 90 minutes
you know we will do fun and of course we
have the lunchtime I'm just kidding and
I can't take the whole lunchtime but we
will see how it goes couple of things
the goals right the goals and non goals
it's always important today what we plan
to do and we don't plan to do the goals
are to understand data wrangling pandas
focus on API usage give you some focused
time to work through the examples it's
90 minutes so it's naughty there is we
can do a hands-on tutorial that kind of
stuff I don't know what that per you
folks got a chance to download the the
you know download pandas and ipython
notebook and also the the data and the
code is in github so you can you know
get it from github and you can do that
one if you you know after this is over
it can go and download the notebooks run
them through the data is there so that
you can take a look at it and you can
understand the mechanisms and mechanics
lets theory and more usage and
straightforward as possible if these
programs are a simple straightforward
programs they are not to you know that
way we go to the pandas not and this is
the foundation for the next two
tutorials a visualization as well as the
time series these are the two things
coming up probably they stack up one
after the other
those are the true ones that only can
work on you know not an expert pandas of
course not you know we have to get
through the first level to get to that
second level time to do hands-on only 90
minutes and there is things like you
know one of the questions that come up
with Python Python and data science is
people look at it and say okay how does
it compare with our and various other
languages right so coding Shakespeare
like come to I come to discuss pandas
not to place our or whatever it is so
that one and no interactive and hands-on
a stop me anytime anything cetera if you
don't understand something or if you
have some questions if you have some
thoughts if you have some ideas stop me
and I do want to thank them you know
folks standing on the shoulders of
giants I have a just a blob about me the
things that I do I'll skip through
because we have 90 minutes so the
installation
pandas are best done with anaconda and
the ipython notebook these are the two
the thing depending on your operating
system you know whether it is lack of
UNIX or Windows you can install anaconda
it has PI you know ipython and various
other things and you can also install
the jupiter notebook the tutorial
materials are here by the way if you go
to the my github
it is there in the in the name of the
you know if you look at the description
I do have put there as well if you go
there you also have a link to the slides
so you don't need to write down the link
to the slide slides are in SlideShare
but if you if you can't get to the
SlideShare maybe I will put a PDF in
here as well so that way everything is
in there I haven't done that but I will
do that one so let us quickly you know
just to get this up and running right
you you have usually okay this is a good
one to see how this thing works out
because
most probably I will put it in this mode
rather than the slideshow it's a lot
easier then you can see it anyway right
yep and it is not much in there let me
see how much you can see this guy I do
have this thing so that I can actually
show more you know more this thing how
does it look and can everybody see this
one I want to see let me I'm going to
just walk down and see well how much
what I will do is I will I will show if
I show this guy does this make it easier
to see good so then what I will do is I
will focus on this one so Jupiter
notebook right when you type in that one
what happens is it starts up if he had
installed ipython and everything it will
start up so I am using the older
directory but you will see that this one
a pre-flight check so this is the
pre-flight check notebook you click on
the notebook and the recipe the
pre-flight check so in order to run
something what you do is you press shift
enter right you go to a dis thing you
press shift enter you press shift enter
it comes in you will see that you know
when you do the this thing you will see
the version number say it so it is just
a starting right so that it tells you
that the ipython is installed and you
have all the other things in there so
let us hold it there so so this is how
you know you start up use ipython to
start the thing in so let us go back
so quickly go through what does this
mean in terms of a pipeline right
we'll do it only a couple of times
because I just have a few slides in the
beginning and then so when you talk
about a data science pipeline like where
does pandas fitting in in the in the
reom of a data science pipeline you have
the colored store and transform this is
where data comes in from multiple places
you start collect and collect also could
be distributed collect the various other
things things like Kafka there'll be
various other instructors in place where
you collect the data and of course to
again the store could be HDFS it could
be distributed storage it could even be
things like a central kind of stuff and
then you know if you have the transform
so this is where the pandas is right you
have data coming in from multiple places
you want to take the data you want to
slice it you want to change things
around you want to do various things
that is where the first thing comes in
the recent model and deploy this is a
machine learning part that is secure
data science where you look at the
various parts of the data you have you
create a model and as I try to you
create the model in the end you deploy
the model right so now you will you know
your program your machine learning your
model you are AI think is out there in
the world and then things like
visualization recommend predict those
more are in the UI side like the UI and
the interactive your application might
are multiple things so that is that is
just a general this thing a lot of the
work in pandas is in the transform and
probably on the model right because when
you have data you want to look at the
data you want to look at matter if we
will we will do some of these things as
we move forward couple of things right
down Tom's well probably is is an answer
data scientist like the key is this when
you do machine learning when you do data
when you do these things right but what
you are getting be very careful that
what you are getting is a slice of the
data a snapshot of the data right and
then you look at the data so that is not
the whole world so be be careful of that
one and so you might look at the
inference for example there is one thing
that one of the data that we will look
at is the
you know people click and by pattern
alright so in that one it looks at it
and says we will give you like 33
million clicks right soft clicks people
click on all kind of items and there is
also a buzz and then they look at and
say okay and now predict can you predict
out of these clicks how many will buy
right when you look at it and say there
might be say like probably there might
be say hundred thousand items and the
buys might be only twenty or thirty
thousand items right so from that one
you can't assume that worst of the 70
thousand items nobody is going to buy
remember if you look at it and say if
the data is from say March through
September or something and there might
be items like this Massoud Robbins right
which they will beach people wouldn't
buy unless and until you have the data
from December so the key is to make sure
so there are things that you know and
there are things that you don't know so
people keep always keep that in mind
when you look at the data when you you
know very especially when you're looking
at averages you are looking at various
standard deviations you are looking at
various other things you group by that
supplied cetera but make sure that
things that we are this is only a slice
of the data there is this huge world out
there and things do change as well so I
just wanted to bring that up I'll just
pass on this one and let us quickly look
at the API sweet pepper the pandas API
so the idea is probably you all know
pandas but still I just want to make
sure that we have a you know everybody's
on the same page that was affect the
pandas
oh so far the pandas is a layer over
numpy a very nice layer is probably a
slightly thicker layer with lot of data
this thing right Brandon says as Brandon
says right in pandas nothing is
impossible so it's a it's interesting
this singlet you can do that but you got
to figure out how to do it now there are
two important data models right the
series is a column series is a Cora and
it is it is somewhat like an umpire
alright now we will see that why how it
comes together and the second data frame
of course data frame is the data
scientists in
the best rapport and data frame of
course is a 2d it is like a spreadsheet
it has columns and it has rows the key
one of the area another interesting
thing is you have operations like for
example if you look at correlation if
you look at string split various other
things right
usually in Python these things act on a
one of one variable right if you give it
a string and that says play you it split
the string but they have extended it so
that when you do is split on a data
frame for a series you get another huge
column right it splits each one of them
when you say correlation it does a
correlation or when you say covariance
we will see all those things so and when
you say right so these these functions
act on the on a column or on a data
frame we will see how that comes
together
pay attention to the index the way the
pandas works right
the pandas is not an array so you cannot
just say give me the zero this thing it
is labeled Rose and label the columns
keep that in mind again we will see as
we move forward so that is let me do one
more slide just to say the objects you
have the series objects you have the
data frame the panel for D and index I'm
I'm using the index in one or couple of
places otherwise it this so this one IO
is sweet you know you can you know for
the we we see us we can be fievel's you
can read the gbq that is a go Google
bigquery right BB cube you can read any
of those things you have the
computations and then it's interesting
missing data again will come when we
come to it I'll discuss more on the
missing data how that works out the data
the the whole date time functions lot of
date/time functions right do you take
that it's apart all of these things are
under the dot DT namespace and then you
have the dot STR string operations and
dot plot the reason this is this
namespace is important because when you
are looking at something you'll suddenly
look at and say maybe you will look at
them say data frame dots
but it won't work right then you look at
them what's going on then you look at
them so I split this see how they see
our name is the namespace say you look
at it and say STR so data frame that STR
dot split or immediately it works so
it's easy to the a namespace and how the
APS are organized so it's important to
understand so that way you know where to
find what this is just a data fit in the
slide so that you know when you know P
you can take a look at the slides when
you look at the slides you will see some
interesting things you can think about
it that kind of stuff so without further
ado let us look at the basic maneuvers
right basic maneuvers we go back into
the first let us get rid of this person
we have the basic maneuvers which is 0 1
0 so now let me see
I am going to try command + and if that
works it makes it easy for all of us to
see how does it look
is it good enough because if I do a more
ok I'm going to hold it there so you
might see something cut off from the
other sides but still you can see that
one right you can see from the back end
here ok yeah fine right ok good so first
one is always you know you know just I
have a couple of the single date time
item number one right that I in and out
data in and out it which CSV it which
delimited text files all of these things
we have our data in a CSV file so we got
CSV data and we have the table they so
this is the car mileage data that we
have let us look at what exactly is
there you read the data the basic
operations right the first thing you
want to do
when you get a dataset you want to look
at and say what how many rows right what
is this data all about you look at it
and say yeah this is there are 32
records in this one miles-per-gallon
displacement HP torque you know are a
ratio rear axle ratio carburetor
balanced number of speed which way you
release a toy this is this car data set
which has a few attributes right look at
this guy right you see that car
somewhere there torque is 30 instead of
32 you know why why it is 13 shut up 32
it is because n a n right because for
two items there is no torque in there so
we will see now we will see how to
handle these things and what do we do
about it so the other basic operation is
he just if you type DF cars it won't
show the whole thing it will show some
part of it right there because this is
only smaller that otherwise what if in
appendices in a father is if you have a
record for example by the time we get to
the axis it has like 33 million records
it's not going to display 33 million
records here by that you know what it
will do is it will throw the first two
20 and the last 20 or something of
course I'm not going to do this on that
one but still that's what it will do it
knows you know it looks at it and says
okay let me show some but you know
anyway keep in mind so it's okay this is
it this is this is a good one right you
look at and say give me the head three
give me the top three and let me take a
look at it there is another one is
described described gives you the count
mean standard deviation the quartiles
maximum mean right so so now you can
look at you get a feel for it oh yeah
there is this miles per gallon these are
you know these are the kind of things
that is in there exercise so describe
gives you a quick snapshot a nice
snapshot that you can figure things out
by the way if you if you give this is an
interesting one right so when you do
this right when you square bracket and
you put those things in you're giving
column label when you give a column
level wherever it takes a column label
you can also give a list so keep that in
mind right so that you can you get
multiple columns you get a subset of the
columns you don't get all the columns so
you can do that one you have that if you
have the head you have the tail of
course another important one d types
right once you read some data you also
want to know what types they are right
whether they are integers date it supply
etcetera so d types are important so
these are so if you look at D types
tail head describe that gives you a feel
for how these things are the indexing is
the labeled indexing right there pay if
you index zero you get this one if we
will we will you know but once once we
start indexing we will come back to the
indexing but the key is you can index
any row and say give me that this guy
right see this one right this is like
this it is it is you know it doesn't
look as interesting as this one right
when you do just the give me the give me
there's a rumor car start mpg dot
egghead that we are taking one column
you know what what this object is right
that's a series object because it's a
column so it's what I was talking about
then you when you look at things some
things might be series some things might
be data frames you have to keep an eye
on both yes sir
excellent excellent excellent question
thank you I was yeah so the question is
what is the difference between a lock
and lock excellent question thank you
first of all pandas is not an erect
right pandas is not an array right so
that you can you cannot just say 0 what
it has it has row it is indexed by row
row it has row labels it has column
levels labels can be anything right so
in one of the things about Brandon
mustard
thing about the label could be the if
you are taking the movie datasets right
the the label could be the movie name so
you can actually index it by the movie
name that is all fine now somebody says
give me the fifth record how would you
do that one so the eye lock if I am
correct is it will give you the fifth
record but if you say lock it so happens
that in our data right in our data in
our data that is why see in our data the
index is the index and the number of the
row is the same but it need not be
tomorrow you could move it and you can
say put the name of the car or something
in there and then then when you do the
fifth one you will get that so I love
gives you the fifth element fifth row
but lock gives you the raw with the
label it so happens that it is five but
it could be anything
does that make sense so anyway that was
the question the question was what
difference what is the difference
between a lock and lock thank you and
this is exactly the reason I put that
one in so that you know it does then I
said oh I said let me make sure that at
least we get this thing out this is the
reason I was saying earlier two things
are important probably three things are
important but the third thing the third
were letters but the first one is the
objects series versus data frame we will
see that when we start looking at more
data we'll look at and how it is why I
why is this thing happening that's one
and the second is this indexing like you
want to make sure that you are able to
index it it is not you can just go in
and willy-nilly take something out and
you don't want to write because if you
have 33 million records in sitting there
if you can handle one two three and you
can put it in here you have to deal with
it in aggregate you want to deal all the
columns and the data in aggregate and
you need to do things with it so the lab
we went to the level dinner sing good so
then see you see this one this is what I
was talking about site you can index it
by by label you can index it by column
name wherever it takes column name you
can give a list of column column so that
then what happens is you get more than
one column so you get a subset of the
columns
so now let us go into and one of the so
we went through this one right read in
and out you know that what you can read
what you can you know this one basic
operations head tail we saw these things
labeled indexing that's what we were
talking about just now
NN remember we were talking about the
torque for example right when we did
that count is only thirty dot when you
have said that assigned for something as
a data scientist you know that they all
data right data is not going to be clean
hey you have you are dealing with lot of
data there might be data might be
missing that a format might be wrong
somebody might not have and there the
data it's not somebody entered the data
when you do the you know when you do the
ETL some pieces might not be there that
kind of stuff right so now suppose you
want to model a in a buying habits of
people how do you handle it like you
have you have some pieces or you have
you know like 30 attributes or 50
attributes and some pieces are missing
in various other places what do you do
with it right what is the most obvious
way of doing missing data drop it right
right that's what is you drop it
it's good you can drop it but what is a
problem that means suppose you have 30
attributes and whatnot two are missing
here or not were missing here we are not
were missing here you when you start
dropping what happens by the time you
start dropping it lock of your data is
gone right because he can isn't fine so
then what is the next best alternative
impute thank you right and impute data
right now the curse is that's fine so
what you are going to do is for the
pieces of data that you have you want to
put things in which is good excellent
so then what do you put in there
yes yeah
excellent excellent thank you thank you
because imputation itself is a because
you can do mean right you can do mean
mean is fine but then it might not be
right if the the the mean almost assumes
a normal distribution of the data right
that's what you are putting in mean but
your data might not be normal
distributed
just for example right you might have
say for example you are looking at some
readings for say health reasons right so
if for sick patients what might happen
is the readings are high right and if
for example you know very rare diseases
99 percent of the data will be you know
one we won't be high and only a few of
them will be right so now if you put the
mean what happens all of them you are
putting all of them as healthy people
that's not right
so what you have to look at actually is
look at and say I have this data 99.95%
of this time this value is between 10
and 30 and probably come on in guys come
on incidents so 99% of the time you know
99.5% of the time it is between 10 and
30 but point 5 percent of the time it is
hundred and twenty right so now this
particular field you have about 500
say hundred data is missing so if
hundred data is missing you are now
going to put everything as 15 you have
to look at it and say 95 of them are
between 10 and 30 so you have to do some
random this thing and say 10 20 22 23 50
and then 5 percent of it you do how to
put like hundred hundred and ten hundred
and twenty years ago
so you know so there are it's more and
more interesting anyway I'm not going to
go deep into it there is also another
story enn right the missile
yeah yeah yeah it's so we have the yeast
now so so the the excellent question let
me go back and I had it somewhere here
anyway the is null is the one to figure
we will we will we will do that one here
as well right there so because remember
you have to look at it and say is null I
also it we have this one is null in this
column and you can do many things you
can say is null you can pull the car you
can pull actually the rows out you can
do many things with that one then I but
remember each column is this a this is a
heterogeneous thing right so you cannot
you know the a average of eight it's not
the same as average of fare or something
else so yes you can do is null and it
will give you the whole thing but you
have to treat it in a column by column
and and if you want to do it you have to
go surgically and say this column is age
so I am going to take an average age
this column is something else I am going
to look at it and there might be
categorical columns for that matter so
that is very you know thank you it's an
interesting discussion I hope you know
you sit through the lunch and maybe the
dinner as well but it is fine because
the NA is an important one this is one
of the this is one of the interesting
ones and and upon ourselves a lot on
that runway helps a lot means eat eat a
six or seven functions that sabes it can
go does that make sense
absolutely absolutely yeah yeah yeah so
even though pandas gives you only six
primitives panda doesn't give you all
those things so for example the the
Titanic data that we will see the lot of
age is missing so either you can put the
ages average age or you can look at it
and say mrs. Miss Junior it's abandoned
say what is the average age of missiles
which is a name in there right so I look
at mrs. and Miss and Miss and master and
that kind of stuff and look at the what
is average age and then based on that
one I can actually impede yeah
so you have an in place equal to true
you have an in place equal to two if you
do in place equal to true it will go and
change that one otherwise it will return
a different work yeah
in fact in place equal to true is there
in many of the other transformations as
well by the way and just to give you
this thing I also you know I'm writing a
book on spark Apache spark and that kind
of stuff right so there are like that's
an interesting so if you use Apache
spark for example the all the the the
ApS are are very similar so the the data
wrangling that I do here I have also on
the Apache spark as well so it's an
interesting one but their heat always
gives you a new one there is no in place
in spark it always gives you a new
ability
one more point on naa and then I will go
and then is always you can't look at it
and say it's bad it's not so for example
the recommender that's happening on the
other side of the room right when you do
collaborate you filtering right what
what happens is you suppose you know you
know that you have you have rated two
movies somebody else are rated five
movies and if there are common ones
based on that one you can say whether
you like this movie or not which is all
fine but if you get somebody right who
hasn't rated any movies and then say
okay you give me a recommendation for
this person what would you do you can't
do anything right so you have to return
on na na and it says I don't know so NN
is good and and if that is there maybe
you can do when you do count and various
other things it will give you an N and
you can look at it and say oh I in this
data there are these many things that we
have no clue about so one day an N is
good because if you put 0 in there is no
difference between 0 and if you have a
zero rating you don't know how do you
say I don't know versus actual zero so
so NN is good but you have to treat it
you know and pandas has a skip an A and
fill in a and interpolate the
interpolate is 7 where you can do
interpolate all kind of stuff is s
interesting ones in there moving on
so you know droppin a is one you can do
drop and they say for example you know
remember earlier when we did this one it
had so now when you do this one see
thirty right because earlier we had
thirty to drop an eight or cut those two
records which had this thought to be in
it there is a skip na fill fill in and
interpolate these are some interpolate
is you have got interesting functions
where he can do he can interpolate this
one so this is an interesting okay see
this data right this is from Brandis
this thing he gets this report which
says sales a sales you know you have the
royalty this is USD
this is GBP and this is euros right so
he says I want a column which says how
much how many how much amount the
customers spend right which is unit sold
bailiffs price which is fine but then
the problem is that currency is
different at different different rows
right here you have USD here you have
GBP here you have you are so how would
you how do you fill that in right so
this might be a good thing to look at
dylaney and how do you do that so what
do you do is I'm just quickly going
through because I think first of all you
do the drop na to get rid of all these
spaces right first you do the drop in it
you get the drop I know you get this
like this it is good then what do you do
you go in and amount spent which is a
new column sales star you know units
sold stands this price right which is
fine which is straightforward you add a
column which multiplies the units sold
versus which place you are in good shape
that is good now how do you put the
currency in any thoughts
where you have the currency you have the
currency sitting here right yeah
so thank you so the first is what you
have that this thing here right so the
first thing you can do is search for
things in between brackets right so you
get USD you are and most of the things
will be an a right and then what do you
do you put it in this column so X okay
I'm going to now you have to bear with
me in the sense I because I have the
whole thing in one column I need to
split it so that I can show you how this
happens right so I'm going to what they
say is you should never try these things
in here they're doing with the audience
I can't fly in it so this is what you
remember this STR so this is where
number that we talked about this string
functions on this STR namespace right
STR SUV STR and you have this rejects
thing right
what you are looking for is you are
looking for things in between brackets
and when you find that things in between
bracket you are going to create a column
and put it in there right which is good
so so this is number the STR functions
act on a column right it is not on a
this thing so when you do this they have
to okay so the first thing I have to do
is to run all above right it has to run
because I haven't been running these
things right so let me run these things
so maybe I didn't have to run this one
so let me do this guy let me do this guy
yep sales is there so let us go down and
these things are there so first thing we
did was drop in a like you drop all the
frivolous columns so now you have got at
least everything is impact this thing
now let us go down and you know just get
the head one more time so that you know
so you know you you add that you add a
new column which is very simple after
adding the column what is our next thing
we search for the currency we search for
the currency actually I should say we
hunt for the currency we do we got it
right see tons of nain 1 USD tons of an
A and 1 GBP tons of an A and one you are
right because because the brackets were
only here they were not here now what do
we do you have a field name right what
do you want to do we want to fill n/a
you want to go up to USD and then fill
the guys up with you asleep right not
down right so there is a thing in
Finland a method is back fill so you go
in fill in a back fill see what happen
it went in and we got nice currency
thing on the top right so I thought that
it was an interesting very interesting
you know parallel parking because over I
I come from Volvo's right who are on I
was driving in that kind of stuff right
so parallel parking and maneuvers and
autonomous driving nearly all this thing
so anyway
see how seeing how we were able to use
here NN was good right because you had
an ale and you are able to say some of
these are USD and various other things
you go in you looked at it and said give
me back fill back
you're able to film this as statistics
are going back switching back into this
one mean in a quantile correlation it
gives you the whole correlation or if
your covariance all kinds of stuff is
there if you want you know so this guy
right this one this returns one number
right what is the difference between
this and this correlation this
correlation acts on a data frame which
returns another data frame with with
right it is a cross correlation between
all the variables here we went in and we
said give me the correlation of
horsepower versus weight so this gives
so now we are doing a correlation on a
series and that gives a number because
you have one series and say okay give me
a correlation between two series is
nothing but a number right because they
you know it looks at the correlation
that gives you a number so this is where
you keep an eye on what type of objects
you have what type of operations you so
then there is a plot you can you can do
the plotting etc etc so I'm going to you
know oh yeah so this is one the group by
probably is one of the most powerful
ones right you want to look at we have
this car HP and beige and all kind of
stuff and miles per gallon and you want
to look at it and say what am i think
and transmission what is the you know
which one has better mileage right so
what do you do you group by automatic
and then you find that mean right so you
say take all the automatic so this is
the thing they call split apply and
combine you take the data split it by
automatic so or automatic equal to zero
goes in one or automatic equal to one
goes in another this thing right and
then what you do you apply a a function
which is basically mean in other places
we will do some
Madhavi we'll see how that happens and
then you combine that together so you
get a tiny you get an interesting
register right so the this to frame is
if you do this right oh I'm going to try
this if it doesn't work don't hold me to
it it's because we haven't done other
things but probably it will work right
if you don't have this to frame we got
what is this guy it's a series right
because it's it's a column so when it's
a column it gives York series of course
you know we are all want to work with
the data frame so you do the frame you
get a nice data frame out of it we will
see more when you go into anyway so this
is a group I keep this in your mind
right you can do group y various other
things so we are in good shape so we saw
the statistics you have Pearson
correlation various other things
Spearman correlation etcetera etcetera
this other group buy as well so this is
a good time so now now that we
understand the basic maneuvers now
exactly 11:30 see guys I heard that 1130
marker there because I had always this
thing on there which says this is where
I should get to this thing and we
exactly go to that one thank you you
have been a good audience anyway because
we have only 90 minutes so I need to
cover the whole thing right even then I
have more than what I could cover so
anyway now let us look at data sets
right now this is a time to look at data
sets let us look at some data as we know
what the basic things are before we go
into data set there is another one merge
right world is like the joint you merge
two you know two data frames we will see
how the merge works join is he said you
know they also have joined which is a
much a subset of merge so always use
merge we saw the group by we also talked
about spit applied combined another
thing is stack and unstack
so what happens is we so this is these
are the things where you will no more
when you run it rather than looking at
it from this person say anyway just to
keep in mind um okay so let me take from
my ad tech experience right you have you
have the TV data set right people who
watch that kind of stuff right then the
the one of the column is the type of the
genre for example right you have or
which I'll adventure it's a fire starter
right now and then you have all these
things people watch an agonist or now
you want to look at it and say no III
need to take this thing and make it a
collar so it's a transformation right
you take it a column and turn it into a
column heading and on based on the rows
we will see that one I'll show it but
anyway so what happens is it turns this
thing around
it turns based on one column or we will
see that one so the the group my and
Marge and group by and unstack these are
the two powerful ones we will see that
one leg because so this is our next this
thing you know so so how many of you
have heard of the gaggle competition
right yeah good excellent excellent
excellent
so that means you have done the people
most probably you have done the the the
Titanic that is one of the classic ones
right and probably you have done the
Titanic using pandas you know the
Titanic data set so let us look at look
it up
so let us employ our new phone you know
powers right the ability to manage this
one let us go in so you have the train
data set first is count this should
bring tears to our eyes you know what
happened right 740 mate only sign
hundred and fourteen has AIDS and us of
them don't help right so that means we
have to drop all of them and remember
what we are predicting we are the
passenger
by the a.classname age etcetera etcetera
so what we are predicting is whether
they survive a lot right so age is an
important factor right there will be
maybe ages in Umberto Foggia wait for
probably ages so now we need to figure
something out so this is what one of the
interesting thing comes in you'd have
the head we look at it yes we have the
you know we see I saw a cabin embark
ticket you know this which says pair and
children sibling you know the spouse
right so what it shows is whether this
person is a sibling because the idea is
that maybe if you have somebody with you
you have a better chance of survival
than if you are nobody right nobody who
cares why right so no no no we need to
get this person out of this one maybe
maybe not
anyway describe gives your description
and you know we do the describe and here
you can see that age gives you this na n
because it can't do these things because
there are n N and a just missing and it
is missing it's just no I can't do this
one so the first two are right let us
look at and say whether gender made any
difference
on the survival right so what you do
group by sex and survived and then the
operation that you do is size naturally
you get the you get a series right you
see this one this has got double series
right so this is a multi indexed there
are two indices on it the first index is
the gender and the second index is the
survive right so so that this is the
data and this is the index right so now
but if you look at it here right how do
you how do you total them and how do you
take percentages right you don't want to
go in and take rows and start
multiplying oh yeah add Row one and Row
two and then you know and then you know
Rho 1 by Rho 1 plus Row 2 and Row 4 by
the price of the right what you want to
do you want to take this survived on the
right so you want to take that column
and bring it to the top what do what do
we use and stack thank you and we use
unstack now we are in good shape right
what happened is you get 0 & 1 and then
you get the so this is what I was saying
unstacked by explaining won't work but
when you look at it it naturally looks
at it and says oh yeah if I so this is
very when you do group by usually when
you do group by and when you have group
by multiple columns you get into a
structure like this right
remember these are the labels they are
not in their part of the data but they
are pandas consider some as labels right
so and then now you want to turn them
around and say I want to get a nice you
know data frame out of it you do the
unstack and when you uncheck it you get
this one now when when you get unstacked
then you can also rename the columns
like that then alive you rename the
columns and then you add a another
column it says total it you do want the
total number of males and the total
number of females you get the total and
you get the percentage does that make
sense - see how we you know we were able
to apply the group by we were able to
apply the
unstack we were able to add columns and
then we were able to you know do the
column operation and we're now you can
see that you know 74 point 74 percent of
females survived and only 18 percent of
the males are white so anyway so just
you want to show that so that you see
how the manipulations come and you know
how these things work out we could have
done there is another thing called cross
tab the cross tabulation so the cross
tab also will give you the same thing
so interestingly you know without all
these things we could have used cross
tab and we could have got on the cup
cart and a similar structure then the
rest of the stuff is you know yeah I
have to show on this thing
so fine so let us get a simple model
right very simple model you know let us
say that all males survive right just to
see what happens so we make a simple
model again pandas helps us right you
have a lambda it says you understand
this maneuver right this is just a
double indexing right you have 0 & 1
and if it is male you you get 1 so you
get the first one out of it and then you
apply that one
so you apply so so this is the test data
right you have the test data so if you
apply this model and you get a survive
survive or equal to all males survive so
don't go into the in the inner semantics
because we are not doing machine
learning we are just looking at how we
can do the thing I wanted to point out
one interesting thing on that one so
this is good so let us do this guy right
let us do the group by say survive and
sighs and unstack right so what happens
you get this n am you know why right
because I'll show you why right if you
do this cakes
this is a good one probably I hope that
it is the error that I'm looking for
here or sorry
because something I did this one that's
way because what I have to do is I have
to go here and say because I have in ran
that thing so what you do is run all
about this is an easier one if you are
running that 33 million won that would
take some time so I would not run it but
this one we can run right so then what
we wanted to do was we wanted to do this
one and size right so because you know
because our model is that all males
survive right so so you see this one
there is no the female one or male zero
right so when you do unstack what
happens you get a nail the reason I want
to point out is when you do unstacked be
careful you will suddenly get this
enhance which were not there before
right because what happens is when you
are unstacking you are you are you know
you're taking all these things and
putting it there so when you do that
when there might be rows that are not
there right you would not have seen it
or you wouldn't have noticed it when you
just use the earlier one but when you do
this one so be careful that's all you
know when you do unstack and then scan
appear so once you do the unstack or
things like that you should check for an
A and then you need to you know account
for it so that's all what I am going to
do on this data there is always there is
more in here I actually have done some
machine learning and a tree and you know
regression trees and random forest model
and that kind of stuff these are more on
the machine learning said I'm not going
to go through that one but we have them
here you can take a look at it and if
you have any questions in affecting me
I'll go through it so this is good so
now we have gone through one data set
oh yeah so let us go through another
data set
that is more that is more interesting
the orders it doesn't right so this
particular data set actually has a lot
more a lot of history to it nothing
serious
I don't know the there is this Microsoft
Access database
remember the the they had some other
database earlier as well right so so in
the very beginning right they that was
the only database available and the
Northwind this is like people who sell
things this data set was supposed to be
the data set to teach you access sequel
and that kind of stuff this was years
ago probably 1990s or something like
that
wendy nurses ruled on that kind of stuff
right now so then i saw this data set
somewhere then I thought oh yeah this is
an interesting data set now instead of
doing sequel and that kind of stuff I
use it for spark and pandas and that
kind of interesting so so that's where
this comes from the data set has ETS
orders so let us read the order data
basically order ID customer ID order ID
customer ID have the employee ID order
date and the ship country right simple
so you have this orders you have the
order details order details have so each
order ID might have multiple lines right
basically these are the lines in an
invoice right you have the each order ID
then it says product at a unit price
quantity discounts that kind of stuff
these are the lines in looking at a
invoice and they also have products and
various other things we are not going to
use the products here they also have
employees so you can use all kind of
strange things in this so we just find
good so let us look at the data orders
orders not count
this is good right there is no missing
data there is no impute in that none of
this this there are details are good so
there is enough detail say mm data
product is there so now these questions
we need to answer
how many orders were placed by each
customer how many orders were placed in
each country how many orders by month
year and then the total sales right
that's what you would look at and say
give me the total sales per customer
and proudly give me the average order
right that's what you look at and say
okay give me the total sales per
customer
give me the average order so which is
fine but do we have all these so first
question how many orders were placed by
a customer what do we have here we have
the customer ID so it's very simple it
is a simple group by operation write a
simple group by operation you do the
group by customer ID size and sought
value so this is how you sort things in
pandas right so you sort the values
because what you want is you just want
to sort the values and so you want to
get the the customers who are the
maximum number of orders right so you
sort values of course you get to a frame
and a head so so simple all right
does that make sense so it says it's a
group by we have seen it before you just
grew by customer Yoda and then you do
some sort values that kind of stuff how
many orders were placed in each country
now we know how to do this one right
it's a group by ship country if you
group by because we have our data here
which says you have a customer ID you
have a ship country you are only looking
at the number so that is why you use and
count or size right you look at and say
okay how many orders are there for each
country Yoda
it's a good it's an easier one but once
we get into the questions three four and
five right how many orders per month per
year or give me the total sales so give
me the average order per customer now we
got a problem right because this doesn't
have two things it does India it doesn't
have any date thing at all right it
doesn't have any date thing to get
monthly everything and it doesn't have
any anything to say what are the total
sales per customer
how many how many things did they
by how much dollars they were hey those
things are here
in the order details so now our this
thing is do you know do pandas thing on
the order details get the rainiest
information out of this game put it back
into our orders this thing then we know
how to do it then we know how to do the
group so let us see how we start doing
that one it's not that bad
step number one we have in our order
details order details is a strange table
right it has this product
sorry that's this way hmmm I see chai
here I feel you know actually I feel
thirsty to drink some chai maybe we
should do it after this is done we see
this guy order ID right you have
multiple lines in an each order and we
have the price quantity and this come
first thing we do what do we do we get
it taut
we get the you know quantity price so
you get this total this thing right good
for unit price you know quantity start
price - discounted thing right so you
get the unit price here and then you
need to aggregate it for all the orders
so that's not that bad keep going going
here first you add the order detail
order detail equal to unit fiestar
normal all these multiplications and
things like that work on a column right
they are not working on a single piece
of this thing okay so you do this one
and then what do you do you are getting
it by order ID right when you aggregate
by already you get this total for each
order right so now a group by order ID
and the and the thing that you use is
some right because now you want the sum
of all the orders do the sum so now you
have the order ID and the order product
so what do we do next
yeah no I mean what we do is we do a
join to the top right so this is where
the merge comes in right oh yeah this
one has a slight problem this order ID
thing right
what is that order ID thing that's a
label that's not a column right because
pandas know but this thing has a this is
the wrong label remember this we were
asking about I locked for example right
if you need if you do i lock one you
will get four 14 I locked 0 you will get
for 40 right but if you do I lock if you
do lock zero you will get nothing you
have to say lock one zero two four eight
because lock is a label right I lock is
a position so this is where the I lock
and the lock comes in the picture but
going back all those guys right one zero
two four eight two four nine and these
are all labels for this guy if you want
to join how do you join so what do you
do there is a thing called reset index
when you reset index this is like that
our number we are talking about this
what resetting unstack similar to the
unstack suddenly this this label multi
index is a single index but multi index
this thing becomes say see that now they
just gave you this number right one two
three four five this is just a number
and then order ID became a normal column
so now you can go back and say merge
what you are going to do is take this
thing merge into the top one and well
you have your order total for each
customers right now we are in good shape
right now we can group by customer we
can group by country and then we can get
the total how much this thing people
came and how do you get the average per
customer instead of some you use average
remember the group by is nothing but a
what is that you know apply and write
it's a MapReduce thing right split split
apply and you know come by right so you
if you just get that group object it
will split and give it to you you can
apply anything you are I mean it's not
anything you want you can apply things
like size group either size average mean
total sum let's apply right so when you
want the average we apply we take that
thing and apply the average if you want
the total we take that thing and apply
the sum on it and that's exactly what we
do we do them all did the merge makes
sense guys no marjaan order ID see what
happened is we had which one yeah hmm
excellent excellent it is by default
it's ready fault hold the thought when
we do another one so it can be default
or you can also give and say left on and
right on and you can give the column
name as well
so - is so thank you thank you very much
the question was is it by default right
that is a good question the reason that
is a good question is because you have
two data set and if you have the column
names the same pandas will figure it out
you don't know how to give it things
like so these are some of the things
that it does right it does that extra
step of going them yes if you have you
know if you have some two names which
are same name but different data then we
are in trouble
but most probably that shouldn't happen
like one of the basic tenets of data
science is that the you should you know
you should always name them correctly
right
whether it is on this table whether it
is on that table whether it is some
other table you have to name it
correctly I mean name it appropriately
because if you have the same name saying
two different things we are in diploma
so so going back we have the order ID
product ID this is our this is our
details from the details we sum up the
total for each order ID so we get a
table which says order ID and the total
dollars for that order
we take this table
and we go back to our orders table has
order ID as well and then we tack in
that order total here right this is the
details this is the order header right
order header has the order ID and so we
get the total here so suddenly we get
this nice table which has all these
things and so you see how we were able
to get in you were able to gather all
these things from multiple tables take
these things up and then put it in there
right now we we need in our question now
you know I'm going to go a little faster
but our question is aggregate by you
know by month and year and that kind of
stuff right so by month and here what do
you do you have the you have the order
date right turn the order date into a
date time we do the date time turn it
into a date time and then remember this
DT remember I was talking about this is
this namespace which has all this datum
we get the month and year out of there
right so suddenly you have two more
columns which gives you month in here
now we are now we are in good shape
right we can answer all questions give
me by giving all customers total of all
customers by month idea what do you do
group by year group by year month and
then some right because you want the you
know you want the the the total right
that's exactly what we do no no sorry
first is how many orders so if you want
how many orders you do the size if you
say okay how many number of orders for
each customer grouped by year and month
see that one this is where the multi
index comes in right you have the year
and month and then I did the reset index
and head so that you get this nice data
framework now the total if you want the
if you want the order total you do the
sum number the the thing is you come you
know you have the split you split by
group so you have these records backed
by the group and then you can apply the
functions that you want you can apply
size then you will get the number of
orders if you are play the total you
the total of the business and that's
about it right there the then you do the
rest of the stuff average by customer
instead of total and this thing you do
the average you do the group by customer
ID and give me the average and you're
done
and you know so now that you you
understand the group by and this thing
you can do all kind of manipulations
with it you take this one and also see
number B we merge the group by the Sun
stack we set index if you have all these
things you're in good shape
set make sense we have we still have
enough time let me see how I am doing on
my time yes epsilon so 20 evan is
actually so so now let's just do some
serious business right so this is the
the recommendation systems you know this
is axis conference usually that happens
every year and during the conference
there is also a challenge so that people
you know do the challenge and then there
is a actually your access challenge
itself is a you know is a track by
itself then about ten or five five or
ten papers of the people who out on the
top this thing you know they discuss how
they did that one etcetera etcetera
so let us take that data so let us get
this guy out
so let us so there was another data that
I was going to use this was the text
analytics so the text analytics was
interesting because what the thing I'm
still you know but I didn't I know that
I end up good times I was not going to
attempt it the idea was to get the the
State of the Union rights to the State
of the Union by the precedence they
reflect the times right George
Washington was not talking about WMD
right he was not talking about Iraq
right so if you look at the set of the
Union and I saw this thing get the
number of words the top the top words
you'll know okay they were talking about
Union and they were talking about
freedom and things like that right now
you don't care about any of those things
right so anyway so that is that side of
the story so so I have the State of the
Union we were able to and then we were
able to compare and say what did Bill
Clinton say that Abraham didn't say
Abraham Lincoln didn't say or what did
the Abraham Lincoln said right the by
looking at the words you can look at and
say oh yeah or Barack Obama
what were his measure of this things
what were the differences we could all
kind of interesting things I have that
thing in there but I don't think we'll
get x I skipped that one by the way I
also how but make sure that this data
only you look at it this is like an our
data this is a the Republican and the
Democrat I'm just kidding it's the
debate debate data right thus I have
that data as well now you can look at
the debate data right and then say what
were the things that the Trump and his
gang were talking about and what were
the things mrs. Clinton mandap Bernie
Sanders were talking about right there
is an interesting things right so I have
all those things in that's going to go
through and use pandas to take it apart
there are a lot of interesting like
split then you have to take common words
out and you have to take commerce out
and you have to take oats out and you
have all kinds of stuff is there but I
didn't get time so you know I'm going to
leave it up to you to but I have those
things in there so it's an interesting
it's an interesting exercise in a very
different way right we don't deal with
numbers you are dealing with words you
are dealing with you know codes words
with comma or words with hyphens
if so now that is a very different way
of looking at it that you have to do
things with that well anyway I'm going
to pass that one and go into this Alexis
right I don't have this data in there
because the data is like about two
gigabyte so I can't put it in github so
what I have done is if you look at each
data subdirectory I have a readme text
in each of the data subdirectory where I
put the lineage of the data where I got
the data from or where you can get the
data from the source and that kind of
stuff so if you want to do this one you
can go to the Alexis 2015 challenge I
have also put the URL in go to the URL
download the data put it in rexis 2015
subdirectory you know unzip it and then
you can run this program this thing I am
NOT going to run it because I'll show
you why so this is you know I can run
this guide I can run this one you can
run this one so there are two files the
so what these files are this file will
take about two minutes to read in right
what are these files so these files are
so this is ecommerce right so these are
the in some sense these are clicks and
vice right that looks like a you know I
don't know it looks like a song group or
or of maybe it's a good good this thing
for an e-commerce thing it clicks and
buys anyway so it has session ID
timestamp item and category so these are
the things that people click you go into
so this thing you click on a particular
item it has a timestamp it also has a
session right so you go in for a
particular in a time click lick lick
lick lick lick you do a few other things
and it also has the Vice right it has
the same session ID the timestamp and
the item body right naturally the clicks
will be huge right it is if you look at
the clicks there are
thirty three million clicks or something
like that right um about 1 million buys
records it is 1 million and the clicks
are about 33 million clicks right so
that is way this data is like about 1.5
I mean actually 1.2 gigabytes total
approximately one point nine three
gigabytes or something like all right so
you have like 33 million clicks and out
of them 1 million bytes you have the
session IDs and that kind of stuff so
our mission if you choose to do so is to
predict right they will give you a set
of clicks and say predict what people
will but hey so now that I says how
would you how would you know what would
you do look at it right so thank you so
you look at it so you have the head you
know the so you look at the count and
the head right so then you have all
kinds of things that you can do right
you look at it and say maybe some items
people buy more frequently maybe some
items people buy on Friday maybe some
items people buy without looking right
because these are utility items right
you're not going to look at multiple
things you look at it and say you look
at it I want this click it buy it there
are other things you spend a lot of time
maybe you do the repeat this thing it's
a price Oprah so there are all kind of
things that we can do and we have this
33 million records here and we have this
1 million that kind of year
so now let us use pandas to look through
this data and I think we have you know
15 minutes to look at it and of course
after that this thing will self-destruct
right so so the first thing yeah there
are two three visas first thing when you
get a data you look at the data and make
sure right anomalous and congruent
incongruencies and that kind of stuff
right things out of that this thing is
not there that thing is not there
because you don't want to make sure that
the data is clean in some sense once you
have that one the second thing is you
look at the data and say
how many items what what did people buy
how many sessions did the every session
became a buy did everything that bought
had a session had a click at supply
etcetera and the third thing is you
extract features you look at it and say
huh I think I need day of the week right
people do things on Monday Monday
probably not many people are going to
buy things maybe Friday people will buy
more things right so if you look at if
you want to predict whether some click
will turn into a bite you look at it and
say yeah this is a weekend I think there
is more possibilities right or you look
at that the day of the week sorry
you know you look at the date you look
at the month maybe some items people buy
during Christmas some items people buy
during this one so if you know how those
things you will be able to do things
right these are some of the
transformations so this is where you
extract the features so we will cover in
a part of these things a little look for
all these things first is verify the
date range right you have the by you
hear the clicks and the vise you want to
make sure that that they train yourself
right if you have some clicks without
any bites or some bites without any
clicks if you can't make anything out of
them right so what you might have to do
is you might have to just believe those
records luckily we don't so so this is
this thing right be the oh yeah so when
we read this one when we the the read
CSV right in the read CSV we did one
trick we did pass dates as timestamp so
we didn't have to do anything the reads
yes we itself passed it and it gave you
them this guy as a timestamp in fact
this is where you know we have that I
say if you look at the D types you will
see that it is a timestamp so that's a
good thing because we already have that
because this time is important if that
is already a timestamp so we are in good
shape there so what we do is we look at
the timestamps and say give me the min
and Max right give me the min and Max of
the clicks and the test and of
and make sure that they are within this
thing and they are right the clicks are
between probably 3:00 a.m. and 2:00 a.m.
on a two days April 1st to 9:30 and
these are all within the word so we are
in good shape we don't have to do
anything on the date side so let us do
some stats right the D types this where
we know session is an integer the time
stamp is a time Sam you know that's the
time stamp we are in good shape so now
we do the count right now we know how
many you know how many records are where
that's the next thing to do and look at
and say how many of the cuts are in
these things we know the count you know
how many records are there that is good
so first question you look at it and say
ha what is the first thing they have
given they are given at the session ID
right so let us look at that and say how
many sessions what what is up with these
sessions are all these good sessions all
these bad sessions first is unique
sessions right so what do you do click
dot session and you do the unique and
size so you know number of unique
sessions you know the number of unique
sessions that resulted in clicks unique
sessions that result in bytes right and
then you do a percentage so you can have
an idea oh yeah 5 percent of the
sessions how no become wise right unique
sessions so that is good because that
means people click a lot of stuff then
under a thing right 5 percent of the
step 5 percent of the time the the
clicks turn into a vice so that's good
thing right so so you see that how we
can do unique we can do size and and
that is how we get that particular thing
out next one same with the Vice right
you give you the number unique items now
you look at it and Siham these are all
items and the people buying all items
then in right if you see people clicked
on say again click item unique right
because we have this when we go back
here the things that we have are session
timestamp item I'm not doing anything
with the category but that's a whole
whole set of things that we have to do
on the categoría so we can do a similar
things on the category so you go in and
say ok
give me the items that's that's
interesting so so people click down like
52,000 items but they about only 19,000
items that's a big keep in mind right so
this is what I was talking about so now
we are not going to say the you know the
whatever 52 - 2032 right about 32,000
items we are not going to say people are
not going to buy them right remember
this is a slice of the data this is a
sample of the data right but people
would buy other things maybe a lot of
times so we cannot just predict and send
up then I'm going to buy those things so
that is where it gets more interesting
right but but be careful that you won't
look at it and say oh yeah because
people didn't buy on the tester data if
I'll be killed in by on the data that we
have we are going to follow that one you
can do that this is where I was talking
about saying that you know the you know
this is a you know there are things we
know and there are things we don't know
when we need to know each like that so
that described so described gives you
count the standard deviation
it's applied so you can look at it and
say I mean if you look at the item the
maximum some people have bought like 144
items in their shopping cart whatever it
is minimum of course is one one or two
or three some age or one right if you
look at it now you can go back and say
give me a plot so you have a plot and
you can look at it and say oh we are
between the mean is probably two or
something like that one or two and then
about 40 50 and then there are this
outlier sitting in right so so you are
able to get that one so oh yeah another
interesting thing right you want to get
the duration like one of the important
thing is if people spend more time on
clicks do they buy or they don't wait
you can look at it both ways maybe you
people are bored and they are just
clicking so if they spend more time
maybe they won't buy anything right if
people want to buy something they will
go and click on it by and walk out so
you can look at this and see if this
session are shorter most Polly you let
me you'll end up buying right because
you know shorter sessions what does the
anyway so now let me ask you a question
how would you get the duration of a
session right
this is what we have right how would we
get the duration of a session so this is
a very interesting this thing right so
what do we do
yes mean at the max of what hmm yes but
but how would you do a min and a max
because this it's not min and that
there's only one number right you have
to go through each session right and you
have to get the min and the max and then
you find the difference yeah you're
saying something mm-hmm yes exactly
exactly exciting so what we do thank you
so group by right what we do is first
remember it's not easy if you look at it
even if even if even if we want to do it
it's not that straight forward right
even if you have to do it what you have
to do is you have to go through each
session and then go through the time
stamp give me the minimum time stamp
give me the maximum time stamp in it
become it so it's just a lot of work in
there right it's not it's a little
generations here and there to get that
work and that pandas does it very well
Evander's does it very cleanly so what
you do first thing you do it is not even
in pandas it's it is easy but it's not
you just have to first thing you do is
you group by session right so you you
group by session you have these sessions
in there right and then so remember when
you do group by session what it does is
it turns this session into an index
right if the session is a column we
can't do much with it but if it is an
index we can do things with it
so you turn that into an index
and you just do a minute let me ask you
this if you do a minute on a column what
would it give you minimum of the column
it will give you one number it will say
this whole column minimum is two but
because this is a multi indexed room of
this is where the label the multi index
the column what does it give you when
you call about minimum it gives you
minimum for each unique index so it
returns a column session ID and the
minimum for that session ID so that's an
interesting one right that's exactly
what you're talking about
but you so now what do you do indexed
column right first you in index it by
session you say give me max give me min
so you actually get two things with the
session ID in there and then you find
the difference you get the duration
right because a max minus min is a
duration so that's that's that that's an
interesting trick to it right so you do
that you do a group by you get this
group by thing and then you do the min
and the max and then when you duration
is min - max again these are all column
operations so in the end you get this
nice column with the session and the x
timestamp which says the duration of
that session so so that's a good right
so it's a very good good nice operation
that gives you that very powerful
operation so now you look at the
duration or describe it surprise that's
all right now you can look at it and say
maximum durations minimum durations you
can actually put this duration into
something else
yep two more minutes so now how many
more minutes do I get after this is over
can I get five five more minutes on how
does it look
so anyway I will quickly there are
actually the you know there are more
things in there the the other thing that
you do is you want to compare click and
so I'm going to take five more minutes
case is that of a fight in maximum ten
minutes to decide okay I don't want to
stand between you guys and lunch but
from the other hand I'm actually more
hungrier than you are probably I might
learn anything so now another thing you
want to look at you want to look at it
and say I want to compare these buys and
I want to compare the clicks and buys
and look at it and say how do they line
up for each item right how do you do
that one first of all you group by
session item and the quantity so you get
this for each session for each item what
did they buy right and the same way on
the click you do the same this thing
right you do these session time and the
timestamp so you know that for each
session for each item how many clicks
they made right now what you can do so
you have the group by and you do a merge
so this is very earlier you are asking
about the the indices right so so
remember these two columns these two
data frames these are indices so when
you do a merge you can say merge on
these two how is outer and left index is
true and right index is true so what you
are saying is don't merge on same name
that columns but merge on the index our
index is basically the session and item
ID so it was just set one peacefully it
looks at it and say so I have this thing
I said is this in yes of this thing and
you layout to join right when you do the
outer join you have that clicks and you
have the bytes right so it will include
all the clicks it will include all the
bias and if you didn't if we didn't find
the corresponding
in clicks it will put na and in there so
this is where we actually wanted name so
then we can look at it and say are there
clicks without bias are there advice
without click second us anyway so you do
that one and and you know and then you
can do count and so you can look at it
so baby this is where you're asking a
question right the e is now thing so I
want to find out if there are any wise
without clicks they are not because we
can look at it and say there is none so
anyway so this is where you can use
seasonal to find out there are more
maneuvers like this right now you know
right you have the group by how these
things and you manipulate with these
things and you get more and more
interesting things the feature
extraction one of the feature extraction
is the soap so this is what I was
talking about right the hour of the day
and day of the week right so you can do
the extraction now you know that right
you create a column you use the DT to
get the day of the week hour of the day
right because you already have a
timestamp so you can actually get these
things in and once you get those things
in you then you do a group by when you
do a group by and you change the and you
change them your group by and then you
do a our join right when you do a group
by and join you will get the number of
clicks per day number of twice per day
you get this guy and then you change
this one and you get this nice table it
says on Sunday these many clicks and
this many buys right now you look at it
and say you can actually plot a graph if
you want to plot a graph right you get
the nice graph plotted because he just
brought it and say hey see see how we
had this huge data right this is like 33
million data right we turned this around
we added columns we did group by group I
have supplied septa and we got this nice
this thing with looks at it and says now
the key comes in here you calculate the
percent if you look at the person that
you really said Monday the percentage of
buys are very low and Friday is where
the
by his habit Sookie if you want so many
brows on mondays right anyway so but you
see that we are able to date this thing
and we were able to mind you this thing
and we get this by the way you can do
the same thing with the day of the month
right maybe maybe on 31st or 30th or
when people buy more things maybe on the
first or second people don't it's a
factor right so you can see that how
these manipulations we can do various
things there are all kind of technique
other techniques and graphs and that
kind of stuff and I think that's where
yep I have some reading list and various
other things in it and thank you this
this where you step for minutes extra
thanks guys questions you can now now it
is your time you can ask